yes the recent suspensions happened I've
been very transparent with you on my
journey through that what frustrated me
is like for it to be like Draymond is
not on this list because of the recent
suspensions like some tough decisions
were going to have to be made this is
Paris 2024 everyone wants to go to Paris
it's going to be fun it's the first
Olympics back open everybody know
everyone in the NBA and the fashion
thing everybody think they're going to
go walk the catwalk probably half the
guys that want to go because of that
reason some of the guys because they
love usab like Kevin Durant love usab
love playing for usab and what that
means and what that brings you got
Anthony Davis going to play Joel MB
going to play batay you going to play
Steph Curry kawi Leonard I probably
wouldn't have made that team anyway
unless it was from a standpoint and he's
been on the last two Olympics and
sacrific during the time when other guys
Wen willing to make that sacrifice the
suspensions kind of gave them an out so
you don't have to face that and I'm
totally fine with that